- Listen to me, don't
think for six months.
No thinking, no valuing how
many views, how many followers.
No numbers, no thinking,
make, make, make, make, make.
Every little awesome creative
thing running through
your beautiful brain
make, make, make, make.
Got it?
- Okay.
(mellow music)
- You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
It is Tea Time as they
call it here in New Jersey.
April 1st, April Fools Day
but no fucking fooling around here today.
We've got a ton of guests
I'm super fired up.
The show is built enormous
amount of momentum.
We are now into day eight of this format.
We are punching corona
in the fucking throat.
I just want to give a bit shout out
to all the prior callers,
I've really enjoyed it
and a huge shout out
to the Twitter community,
I'm honestly going
because I need so much the
action during the two hours
I'm so zoned in,
everybody who's on Twitter
is bringing me so much value.
So if you're tweeting,
especially if you're taking
a screen shot of the show,
and sharing it on Twitter with a link,
the Facebook link would
mean the world to me.
It is in my Instagram profile.
Actually Team GaryVee if
you're watching right now,
please change my URL right now on Twitter
to the TeaLiveStream on Facebook URL
so that people who watching right now
that go to Twitter and
copy the URL from them
#TeaWithGaryVee if you're
sharing on Twitter.
And as we've been doing the whole time
the last couple of days very intensely,
if you're looking for a
follow from me on Twitter
or some more exposure, I
am retweeting and following
all along as people share the show
just like Maddy just did and Aman Kumar
he gets a little bit of a like.
Actually Aman you gettin' a follow,
I am your 28th follower as
you chill in my favorite
place New Dehli, India.
That's right Dustin that
is my favorite place.
Let's get right into the show.
- Ben how are you?
- I'm doin' all right.
- Super well my friend,
where are you from?
- I live in Birmingham
but I actually grew up
in the Northeast, I grew
up in Maine actually.
- Love it.
What can I answer for
you brother, no worries.
- Yeah, I've been
following you for a while
and I really appreciate everything you do
I just want to thank you first.
- Thank you Ben.
- I actually came and saw you live in 2015
in Birmingham, Alabama and
that really set the stage
for me to even believe that social media
was a thing that anybody did.
I was like, something my
sister would do. (laughs)
- I totally get it, I totally get it.
- Yeah and so now I've
really on been all in on it
for about six months and
mostly just posting photos
and everything like that.
And I just, my question
that I sent in was how do I
not feel like an ass
clown on video (laughs)
whenever I start posting,
whenever I post myself.
Like I'm cool posting
the stuff that I build.
I'm a (muffled speaking) contractor
but I also feel really
contrived. (muffled speaking)
- I think it comes down to
not valuing other people's
opinions more than your own
happiness and opportunity.
The fact that there are
so many millions of people
right now that are aware
that lives and podcasts
and blogs and TikToks can change
the course of their lives.
Unlike you pre-'15 the Birmingham talk.
There are plenty of people
that just don't realize
that you can go from zero
to 200,000 and happiness.
Literally go from 80,000
and unhappy to 200,000
or happy or even my favorite one.
From 313,000 a year in
revenue for themselves
job or business and unhappy
to 196,000 and super happy.
Right, they both work right?
Happy is the common bond,
not how much you take home.
There's millions of people
that don't even know
that to be true if you go
and make content on LinkedIn,
YouTube, Facebook, Instagram.
What breaks my heart is more your set.
The millions, the hundreds of millions,
tens of millions minimally
that do know that
that can happy but value
other people's random
comments over living
their best fucking life.
It drives me Ben.
It drives me.
I have a huge thirst for giving back.
A huge just need to bring
value and conversate
and build community and lead
and this is what I've chose to talk about.
There's so many things I could be doing,
I'm sure as a human,
talking about leading on.
It is that we are living
in the greatest era
of opportunity in the history of mankind.
It is called the internet.
You are sitting in a fucking car right now
and I'm sitting in New Jersey.
We are talking to each
other and 10,000 people
are watching, what are like, right?
Could you imagine.
- No, I can't.
- Brother, listen to me.
You have to go into a deep place
and I'm not joking when I say this.
Whether it's 50 therapy sessions,
whether it's meditation,
whether it's playing me
on repeat, whether it's working out.
Whether it's writing things down.
Whether it's having a very
difficult conversation
with your mother, father, sister
of like that, or with yourself.
You have to figure out
how to put zero value
in other people's opinions
over your happiness.
That doesn't mean don't listen to people.
I listen to every comment.
I take feedback.
But, the thought of
not feeling comfortable
in my own skin because somebody might say
that you're full of
shit or you're not smart
or you don't know what
you're talking about.
I'm trying to eliminate that.
We are the world, the world
is stuck in high school.
- Oh yeah, I mean it's the
comments from high school
that replay in your head of like,
some dickhead.
- You're a nerd, you suck.
Exactly.
- And I know that I'm a badass architect
and badass contractor, I can
build literally anything.
- That's amazing.
- And like it's not--
- Have you started producing
content on LinkedIn?
- Um, not really, I've been honestly
just focused on the 180 with the--
- Instagram.
Hey Ben I'm telling you
right now, today, today
post either a video or a written post
about architecture or
building on LinkedIn.
The Linked B2B scenario, LinkedIn
is actually like Facebook in 2012.
You can zero followers.
You don't even have to
have a LinkedIn account
as we sit here today.
You go and sign up for one.
You go and post 'cause now
you can do that in LinkedIn,
unlike five years ago.
And you literally post something,
a blueprint, a picture of
a blueprint and then write
about it.
I don't give a shit.
Talk to them as if you
were talking to a friend
that was interested in
what you had to say.
You will be blown away about
what's going on in there.
Yeah.
And I would argue would lead
to more business opportunities
than Instagram within the first month.
- Okay, so double down on Linkedin.
- LinkedIn all the way, go
hard, pictures of blueprints,
write stories or thoughts or make a video.
And really go deep inside yourself
and be like why the fuck
would I give a fuck.
To me here's the thing that helps me.
When somebody writes something negative
I feel compassion and sympathy for them,
not that they have power over me.
For somebody to take the time,
if their life is so shitty
that they're watching you
and then saying you suck.
They're hurting inside, just like bullies
in fucking high school.
They're hurting inside.
- Yeah, you gotta get over.
I gotta get over myself.
- You gotta get over yourself.
You gotta get over yourself
in a very interesting way.
I like that you said that.
You gotta get over the facade or the way
you've tried to paint
yourself to the world right,
because vulnerability is a very powerful
ingredient in being able
to put yourself out there.
- I was almost had (muffled speaking)
- Shit, Dust, I'm losing him.
- Sorry.
- No worries brother.
Yeah, a little bit better, go ahead.
- So what I typically
do is I put on this fake
persona that isn't actually who I am.
- I love you, I love you
for having the strength
to say that right now on this show.
I love you for that.
That means--
- But it's true.
- Good and that means
you're fucking moments away
'cause you fucking you
could post for the next
fucking year and not have
this many people watch.
So good news.
Like now just start tellin',
you know what I mean.
You're set.
The fact that you can say
that on this show right now
means you're inches away
from going there you know.
- Yeah, but then you
said, yesterday the thing
that you're best at being is GaryVee.
And I was like that's my
fucking problem right there.
- Right you're not best
at being Ben Strouten,
the real Ben Strouten.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Who I am.
- Well listen, listen you're one post away
you're one post away.
Make one video and you
can do it one fucking fell
swoop, here's the real me.
It'll change your life.
I promise you 95% of your
inner circle is gonna message
you on Facebook or text you
and be like, I'm so proud of you.
Because what nobody realizes
when they're the fake
version of themselves is
that everybody already knows.
- That that's the fake version of you.
- 100%.
(Ben laughs)
My friends who are watching right now,
you're not trickin' anybody.
You're fucking not trickin' anybody.
People in your inner circle already know.
All right Ben love you
pal, I wish you well.
- Appreciate it.
- Good start, Ben with some fire.
I'm kinda proud of him.
He's moments away.
Good job Luke, Consella nice
little set up you got there.
You get a retweet on a follow.
I'm you're 122nd follow.
Annie Fried good morning,
you're getting a follow too
in North Carolina, Annie
are you on Wine Text
do you drink wine?
All right Sam, set to go.
There we go my man.
I can hear you great.
- Awesome.
I just wanted to say thank
you for taking the time
to talk to me man.
Getting ahold of you the last couple days
has been honestly kinda surreal.
Just had a lot goin' on
and kind of lost track
and not sure where to go from here.
So my last question, not my last question,
my question is so from
watching you kinda remind
me of my father with
how headstrong you are
and your motivation just doesn't stop man.
You're always going, I
don't know how that works.
- And gratitude, gratitude and ambition.
- Okay.
- When you're grateful for what you've got
versus dwelling on what you don't have.
It actually gives you energy.
- That's always been my biggest problem.
'Cause I mean my dad
is extremely successful
so I was never born without what I wanted.
- Understood yes.
- I don't mean to say that in a rude way.
- No, no, you're saying,
I'm proud of you for saying
that, it's actually hard
for you to say that.
So I'm proud of you keep going.
- So, that whole motivation things of,
well, I already got it so.
- It's hard to be hungry when you're fed.
- Yeah and so--
- But the key is for you not to turn that,
a lot of kids in your spot right now
are turning that into
anger towards their parents
instead of taking on the accountability
that they didn't have to take the money.
- Yeah, 'cause we do battle a lot,
me and my mom and my dad, we battle a ton.
- And you battle about,
how does the battle
go down, what is the cliche battle?
- Well, I gotta a few other,
I have a couple of mental issues going on.
So a little bit of ADHD,
some depression, anxiety,
insomnia things like that.
So that causes a little
bit of extra issues.
- I appreciate that, I respect that.
- So it's just shit that I'm dealing with.
- Of course.
- It ends up causing
problems, you know it causes
with the girl and it causes
problems at home and stuff
like that.
A lot of extra issues that
end of making everybody
else a little bit more tense.
And so I guess where I'm
trying to get is how do I get
that motivation to get that hunger
to go figure out something to do.
When everybody else is kind of ticked off
and you're kinda of trying to make things
less tough.
- I understand.
- Lost the job I've been
trying to get for years
due to this coronavirus thing.
And now I'm like, shit, where do I go now?
- Where you go now is we
need to take a big big
step back
and really like, I think
what we need to frame up
is happiness.
You know like I think
unfortunately like many people,
people get caught up in financial success.
- Yeah, big time.
- Bro, Sam it can not be the North Star.
It can't be the North Star.
You've gotta probably, how old are you?
- 23.
- You know reframing
what you've been thinking
probably for 18 years and
probably 23 years subconsciously
is difficult but to me
I don't want you just
checking the box for, or just appeasing.
I think the thing that
you need to spend a lot
of time on is thinking
about what genuinely would
make you happy.
And you know I think that
you can't look at the world
through your parent's
eyes, society's eyes,
your girl's eyes, a therapist's eyes.
You gotta really look through
the world through your
eyes and then be strong
enough to over communicate.
I think you need to,
there's, when one goes
through that many things,
anger and dwelling
and being sad about it manifests
and it becomes momentum.
When one can start looking at gratitude,
like thank God I'm alive.
Thank God I even have a life.
When people can go to thank
God I'm 23 and I have 80
more years to figure this out.
I could figure this out
at 33 and have a fucking
unbelievable life, all of a sudden
the pressure of figuring
it out right now goes away,
right?
When one says, whether your
parents say this or not
and obviously I've seen both versions.
Whether you need to make a lot of money
or be successful, somebody
can stand on their own
two feet at $45,000 a year,
you just have to have the humility to rent
a shitty apartment,
right, and not have a--
- Right, sorry I didn't
mean to interrupt you.
- No, no you're not interrupting please.
- I think the coolest
thing about my parents
is even through with all
the success that he's had,
he's never pushed it on us to,
you gotta be just as successful as me.
You gotta do this.
- That's awesome.
- I want you to do what
you want to do that makes
you happy.
- That's huge brother.
Do you believe him?
- Yeah, 100%.
- That's huge, do you know lucky you are?.
- Moved out of the house
at 15 to go to boarding
school halfway across the
country 'cause he wanted to.
So I mean it's he's there.
It's just I feel like I'm the
one that's not giving it back.
- Yeah, that's good.
That's good that you understand that.
So what you, I need to figure
out what your ideology is.
See what people don't realize.
You know to me I think a
lot about people's religion.
Like my religion is the Jets.
Right like the one place
that I am not rational,
this is silly but true.
I see it, I see it.
You know is the Jets.
I am not thinking
rationally at a Jets game.
I physically want to, I
punched a Dolphins fan
only 10 years ago, I bumped a 12-year-old
wearing a Brady jersey.
Literally checked him, in
hockey terms, into a fence.
This is things I've done.
I cursed old men out at the stadium.
I get into fights, like
the people with the coats
come in my section almost all the time.
I'm completely inappropriate.
I have no conscience.
I'm not myself.
Now a lot of people are
like that about religion.
A lot of people, like a lot
of people especially now
are like that about politics.
There is no rational
conversation about Patriot fans,
about Pittsburgh Fans,
about Dolphins fans.
And so I understand having
a chapter of my brain
that is so ideological, so
emotional, so irrational
that I can't navigate
through that calm place
where I do in business,
in life, in politics,
in religion and family.
Like I can do that.
I need to figure out what your ideology is
that's beating you up.
You're beating yourself up.
Your entire tone and
demeanor is you're shitting
on yourself when you don't need to.
- Right, yep.
- You don't need to.
We need to figure out
whose opinions you value.
Outside affirmation,
did you grow up the kind
of kid that like gave a
shit about what other kids
in high school thought about you?
- Way too much.
- What were you saying brother?
- I said way too much, I was
agreeing with what you said.
I still think about that shit.
I was relating myself to the
last dude you were talking
about doing the fake me.
Man, I've been doing
that since middle school,
you know what I mean.
So it's just--
- Who's the fake you
and who's the real you?
- That.
- Give me a little something.
Let's play within five seconds,
who is the fake you?
Give me a fake you couple
bullets and give me the real you
couple bullets.
- Fake me is probably really
quiet sittin' at the bar
not doing much, not
talkin' to many people.
Kinda a bit of an introvert you know.
Always been, I guess that
stemmed from high school,
not really wanting to like--
- Put yourself out there.
- Yeah, I just never was that good.
Like this, I'm terrified right now,
just like way too many people. (laughs)
- Yeah, I'm proud of you.
- I appreciate it.
So it's--
- That's fake you.
- Yeah, that's fake me, real me.
I love talking to people.
I want to be around.
That pretty much what you
described being at a football
game is me at a hockey game,
when we're playing the stupid Penguins.
- (laughs) Have you thought
about starting a Lightning
podcast?
- No, never thought of that.
- Have you ever made Lightning
content for an Instagram
account or something?
- I've never really been much
of a social media person.
The one time I really started
posting on social media
was when Trump was getting elected
and I actually got a lot of shit for it.
- Understood, yeah I get it.
- I would be interesting
I've been playing hockey
for about 20 years now, so.
- My intuition, seeing
this show many times before
the interest guides you into the light.
- Yeah!
- Mm-hm.
I've seen a lotta lotta people struggling
with a lot of stuff and
Star Trek or garage sale-ing
or the Tampa Bay Lightning
has taken them into a place.
You know, one hot take is
I think you should start
a media empire, you're
little own media empire
around hockey and Tampa
Bay Lightning culture.
Let me explain how it works out.
You start this Tik-Tok account
which is one of the
places I go immediately.
You start this Instagram account.
You start a podcast, you
call it Lightning Sam
right or some clever name, right.
Bro, you will find your
11 hardcore Lightning fans
in five minutes. (snaps)
All of a sudden those
are the guys and gals
you're going to the bar with.
Those are the girls and guys
you're meeting at the parking lot.
Those are the guys and gals
you're meeting up on Zoom
in three weeks.
In three weeks by using
the right hashtags,
by writing the right
post about the goalie.
By reminiscing about the Stanley Cup run.
In three weeks you've got nine new friends
who fucking love the
thing you love the most.
I can talk Jets football
in my Jets thread,
with my friends and family 24 hours a day.
I think your great love is
what's gonna pull you out.
- Okay yeah, that was what I had found
with my job that I just got
and I love beer. (laughs)
Who doesn't right?
And I had gotten into a
brewery, it was just grunt work,
cleaning kegs.
- But you loved it.
- I loved it man.
I hated servin' tables.
God, I hated being a server. (laughs)
- Listen to me, listen to me.
the Lightning.
- Do it, I think that's an awesome idea
and I've honestly been
thinking about doing a podcast
or something.
I just didn't know if
anyone wanted to listen
to my bullshit.
- There's definitely this
tiny incredibly passionate
group of Lightning fans that 100% want to.
- Yeah, I mean I--
- And guess what else,
you PMing on Instagram now
former players from the
former Stanley Cup team,
14 of them want to be on the podcast.
Because you know this hockey don't get
that at-bat like that.
- That's true.
- A third line right winger on that team
is not fucking known.
But you know who he is.
- I know who Stefan Matteau
is from 1994 Rangers life,
you know what I mean?
- I know who Doug Wade is,
I know Tony Grenado, I know Mike Gardner.
I know my Rangers that
probably a lot of people
wouldn't know from my era.
So punch line is your passion
will pull you the fuck out.
Your passion will pull you out.
I'm telling you, go all
in, create a Twitter,
a TikTok, an Instagram and
start a YouTube podcast
thing and just fucking go.
I'm sure you have one or
two friends that like the
Lightning as well.
- Yeah totally.
- Good, just have them on
the fuckin' first show.
What's your favorite Lightning story?
Did you ever cry?
What was the worst moment, best moment,
when we come back what
do you think about this.
Just fuckin' go.
Just get immersed in making
content about the Lightning.
Go find videos on YouTube,
clip them post them
in your Instagram, write something.
I remember this play.
I was 13, I fucking
punched a hole in the wall.
Whatever.
- Okay, yeah.
- Just immerse yourself
in your passion because
if you make $65,000 a year selling hoodies
and having appearance fees doing that,
you'll be the happiest
fuckin' boy on earth.
That'd be something I'd want to do too.
- Do it Sam, I love
you brother, good luck.
- Yeah and thank you again.
- You're welcome man.
Keep watchin' Sam.
Keep listening to the
positivity and the practicality.
Let me pump in your ears
for a couple years here,
I'll fucking pull you
out brother, I promise.
- I'm about it.
Thank you Gary.
- You're welcome bro.
(sighs)
Getting deep here on Tea with GaryVee.
Mara how are you?
- Hi Gary how are you?
- I'm well.
- I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
I'm a huge fan, I'm probably
the only Pakistani frickin' mom
who's a WWE fan that
you'll ever meet. (laughs)
I wanted to ask you a question.
A little bit of background about me.
I was a stay-at-home mom
for a bunch of years.
I started my own blog about couponing
and how to save money.
(indistinguishable) Every
mom was learning how to save
money and learn how to basically,
get diapers and baby clothes for cheap.
I did that for a couple of years.
I worked full-time for a couple of years,
my kid are a little bit older now.
And I accidentally started
a business last summer.
So my uncle went for the
pilgrimage to Mecca, to hajj.
And when he did that, for a gift for him
when he came back was I
made him a flower garland.
And this is like an old
school Pakistani tradition.
And I made these garlands for him.
And, can you still hear me?
- I sure can, I'm captivated
by this story, keep going,
I love heritage niches
that can be more broad
than people realize, so I
kinda know where you're going,
so I'm just listening.
- Yeah, so he, I looked
around to see where I could
buy garland from.
I couldn't find anyone in New York.
I found one person all the way in Queens,
I didn't have time to go
all the way over there.
So my uncle was like I'll
buy a couple from you
if you make them, so I said, okay
and I made them before
but not really like,
going into it and I made
like 13 or 14 for a bunch
of family members everybody fell in love.
They were like, these are so beautiful,
you need to sell these,
you need to sell these.
So I posted them in this
Muslim networking group.
And I got a lot of inquiries
and people were asking
me but it was towards
the end of the season.
So I wasn't gonna get a lot of orders.
And then all of a sudden
I got my first order
from a bride who wanted to
wear it for her wedding.
And I was so excited and
then I started getting
other orders from brides and
other orders from brides.
And I put it on Instagram
and I really wasn't trying
to promote it hardcore,
it was why whole family.
Like literally somebody asking
me where can I get a garland
they were tagging me.
They were like that person
makes a great garland.
So I'm really lucky that
I have extended family
just blasting my work out there.
I started on Instagram,
I've been getting orders
I'm booked through June.
I actually have people
putting deposits down
from January to June.
Unfortunately now because of the situation
I had to, a lot of my
brides had to postpone.
I'm really lucky that
every bride that I've met
has been super sweet.
I haven't had to deal with a bridezilla.
And you know for me it's
just, I like doing it
because for me to be a part
of somebody's special day
like a little piece of my art--
- It's huge.
- Could be a part of
somebody's special day.
It's a blessing to me.
- Literally every time we
had a customer buy wine
from us for their wedding or bar mitzvah
or what have you.
I would always get a little pep in my step
because I knew it was a special day.
And clothes is way more
powerful than wine,
so I totally get it, go ahead.
- So, you know, these are
fresh flower garlands.
They look like lays almost.
And I've expanded it
to fresh flower jewelry
for these women's tennis ceremonies
and--
- I love it.
- And you know it's not
huge but I'm not looking
to make it huge.
Like I like to focus
on one piece at a time.
- So what's the question
because this is going great?
- My question now is that
because I'm not getting customers
and I don't have flowers on hand,
what kind of content should
I be creating just to keep
that, just to keep myself
visible to a lot of people?
- I think that, there's a
couple things I would do.
One I would consider
starting a Facebook group
for the community around the culture
of these products and so,
just starting a Facebook
group, just to talk.
Just to let people stay in touch.
I think, like I've been
talking about it all week
and last week, story
time, like just the video
of how this even happened
is a good comic book
number one, first album.
I would put out that content.
You could absolutely post
right now in your Instagram
or anywhere else you have a community
or email and say, hey, does
anybody want to come on
and do a video with me, a livestream
where I can answer questions about it.
Now it is about you.
- You don't have the flowers,
you don't have the product,
you're gonna have to make it about you.
Your family's journey from
Pakistan to the States.
Extended family allows
you to put on all of them.
Like this is the time to do story time
and a video of how you think about.
Like the process, people love the process,
just like a story.
When I sit down, I don't know why
but if I look at the bride's photo
or read the email I just
immediately see a vision
and I start working.
You know like it's about you now.
Like the same way that we
fell in love in America
about Vera Wang her story
and her starting it at 40
and coming up the ranks and we need to,
this little subset needs
to fall in love with you.
- Okay, so what do you think about talking
to other wedding vendors
and kind of talking
about what's going on
now and the best course
of action for brides?
- 100%.
Yeah, if you want to level
up and be the dinner host
of the macro wedding
conversation and by DMing
a hundred a day, biz deving that way.
I think that's incredible.
- Yeah, definitely I love.
I mean and I just want to shout out to all
of the other brown moms
who are entrepreneurs
because I'm finding them
like crazy and I'm supporting
them and I'm tagging them
and I'm sharing their stories
and I'm so proud to see
so many women coming.
- Amara--
- You know coming up and
just coming over stereotypes,
I love it.
It's so amazing.
- Unlimited.
Like just so many of the
subcultures of Brown culture
are so entrepreneurial by nature
and the internet
has allowed mom to thrive
in a way that mom couldn't
in 1974 and this is why I
keep going back to gratitude.
The fucking internet, like come on.
Imagine corona with pre internet?
Like we'd get sick of
television, music and video
games pretty quickly in 1987.
You know like what a blessing.
- Yeah, we can definitely
still connect with each
other and our parents and
grandparents didn't have
that opportunity during times of--
- You know what's another
thing back to immigrant
culture, so many people
connecting with their loved ones
now on Zoom and Google
Hangouts 'cause that 60, 70,
80, 90-year-old set is
being forced to learn
some technologies that
they pushed against.
And they're loving it.
So that's been a great gift,
that's been a great gift.
The amount of people that
are going to interact
with their grandma back
home in the old country,
a 100x more over the next
three years before she
passes, that would have
never happened on corona
because it was a once
every six months phone call
and now it's a once-a-week
Zoom on Friday nights.
It's a blessing.
There's so many blessings that are coming.
- My grandfather used
to send audio cassettes
to my dad.
Like that's old school.
He used to record an audio
cassette because they
didn't have a phone.
- When my parents came to America--
- It's amazing how can
connect and we can FaceTime.
- They wrote letters, letters
that took three months
to get here.
I mean so, anyway, Amara proud of you.
Talk to you soon.
- Thank you so much Gary, thank you.
- I don't see Anthony
Fernandez in the building
good to see them.
If you're watching on Facebook right now
for the 4,000+, please
hit the share button
and let's get some of your
friends and family on to
this show.
There's some GIFs and
jewels being dropped.
Let's keep this going.
Hey Lindsay.
- Hi Gary how are you?
- I'm well and you.
- I'm doing good hanging in there.
- Where are you from?
- I'm from the Jersey shore,
so kinda close to you.
So I wanted to tell you
how I actually found you.
You showed up on my
Instagram explore like maybe
over the summer and it
was when you were doing
yard saleing, so that's
kind of like my business
that's what I started out doing.
I grew up from a teen mom, so
I lived with my grandparents,
my mom, we were good.
Things were covered but
like at the end of the
month there wasn't always a lot left over
so we were always like super, always out
at the flea markets or just
trying to make things work.
I wouldn't say I was like entrepreneurial
and then I went to college for advertising
and it was like my school
year we were leaving
and I noticed people
were throwing furniture
away on the curb at the end of the year
and I as like, my neighbor
who had a pick-up truck.
I just grabbed all the
furniture I brought it home
and I sold it on Craigslist.
And some of it I painted,
some of it, I sold it as-is.
And I was like this is insane.
- That's smart.
- Yeah, so I worked in
corporate America for 10 years,
but like painting furniture
and reselling it on Craigslist
and now Facebook Marketplace
was always like my side hustle.
- Your side hustle.
- Yeah and then three
years ago I had my son
and I was like ah man,
I don't want to leave
and go to work and come
home and be miserable.
So I'm just gonna like go
full force into my business.
So I did.
Yeah, so it kind of went
from like painting furniture
and posting it on Craigslist
to kind of getting
a little bit of notoriety in my town.
And then I was taking on commission work
and then I was looking
for places to get stuff
to put on my furniture to take pictures
and then I kinda got into antiques
and it kinda like spiraled.
And then I was like, maybe I
should open a brick and mortar
store, but then I was like I don't know,
that's all a big commitment.
So then I found an antique mall
actually in Point Pleasant, New Jersey.
So I pay them rent.
- I know it.
- And I have a booth there.
And I was like, yes, this is so smart
and so strategic.
I've bided my time, I'm only
paying like $550 a month
on my rent, I don't have to be there.
I don't have to worry about sales.
I can just get my stuff, bring it there,
do the stuff I love, which
is hunting for the stuff
and being creative and
then coronavirus happened.
And my store closed and
I still have to come up
with my rent and I'm like,
I can't go to the flea
markets, I can't go to anywhere
and we're kind of just
like stuck in the house
and I'm like, okay, what am I gonna do.
And like my art and I know you get it
because I saw it in your
face when you were going
to flea markets, it's like
the thrill of the hunt.
Like you must get with a client.
It's like I'm gonna pull,
like you pull something out
and you're like this was $2
and I could sell this for 50.
I can't do that anymore.
So it's almost like you're
like a caged animal.
- I mean I'm so devastated
that we're gonna miss
town-wide garage sale
season here in Jersey
for April and May.
You can't even imagine it's
like running through my mind
left and right.
A couple things stand out,
one you can definitely
garage sale in your own home.
I think people are, it's
unlikely that you have
as much stuff as most
people because you actually
get it.
- In the house my husband's
like, I don't get used
to anything because I know
you're gonna sell it out
from under me.
- I love you for that.
So one, and I mean this,
really going through
everything that's in the
house and maybe getting
a little of that flip
life out of your system.
But two, I have little
bit of an idea Linds.
I think that you can create
a little $15 or $20 course.
And I think your angle is
flipping and creativity.
I think you can put
together and 80-90 page PDF.
- Okay.
- Right, and then also layer
and then market it like this.
Hey, I've created an 85-page
book and I'm doing a once
a week, one-hour zoom or Google hangout.
And it costs $90 and you
get the book and you get me
for four sessions or
however you want to play it.
Maybe you build up the momentum
and launch it in a month
'cause it's gonna take
you some time to put
the PDF together.
- Okay.
- I think what you do,
which is a little bit more
Etsy/thrift store creative.
It's not just what I do, which
is like buy stuffed animal,
sell stuffed animal.
- There's a lot of touches involved.
- You're doing a lot of creativity
and the DIY world.
I was laughing when you said,
I'm not an entrepreneur.
I'm like you are an entrepreneur
and a creative one.
And so my intuition is
you have the potential
of having a community through your inbox,
your email, what I mean by that.
Your cellphone numbers, your texts.
I don't know what you do
on social if you gotta
a little bit of following anywhere.
- Yeah, I have a decent following.
- I think if you put out
like hey, here's an $89
program where you get an
80-page PDF, 60, 40, 100, 12
and you get four one-hour
sessions with me live
in the month from mid-April to mid-May.
I have a funny feeling
you would do really well.
- Okay, I just worry
because my audience now
is like super local to the Jersey Shore,
people that I've met at
like markets that I've done.
And they're like gonna buy from me--
- Yeah, but you don't
know how many of them
want to be an entrepreneur and
want to do what you're doing
and the fact that you're giving
away all your best advice
and Q&A access.
And not to mention that okay
so Pam in Red Bank sees it,
but then she tags her
sister Susan in Australia
who's been wanting to
do something like this
and is creative and she puts
her username in the comments
and then she's the one
that actually buys the $89
you know ebook and access.
- Okay.
- It is a good point.
- And then like in terms of
I just feel awkward right
now hawking pieces that I'm working on.
- Yeah, I think you just
write the copy up front,
which is like first and
foremost I hope everybody's
healthy, I have no,
obviously all of us are going
through this struggle.
So please before you
even look at this desk,
you don't know that I'm super empathetic
and care about everybody
first and foremost
but at the same token I'm
also trying to provide
for my family and so here's my desk.
I think if you write
the hedge in the first
two sentences I think it will help you.
- Okay cool, I'll give it a shot.
- All right, good luck Lins.
- All right thank you so much, take care.
- You got it goodbye.
All right let's keep this going.
Paul V thank you so much.
Big shout out to Charlie
Whitmore, with the share,
gets a follow number 437.
Hello.
- Buenos dias!
Oh my God Gary Vee my heart
is pounding really fast
and I help people deal with their nerves
and their confidence.
Thank you so much!
- You're welcome.
What's your name darling?
- Marissa.
- Marissa so nice to meet you.
- Marissa Caskarelli.
I am the daughter of Dominican immigrants
into Washington Heights,
the wife of an Italian
immigrant himself came when
he was 11 and I knew about you
and followed you, you
know dabbled in your work
at first.
And then I saw you with
Sasha this weekend.
And you guys just stole my heart.
(Gary laughs)
Thank you so much for your
authenticity and everything.
I am a white chocolate mom-preneur.
So a Dominican White woman,
Brown woman whatever,
I don't give a shit, I
don't believe in labels.
It puts us in boxes.
My passion.
I came from a background.
I was a performing professional ballet
and contemporary dancer with
Ballet Hispanic in New York
and Twilafar and a bunch of great people.
That was like volume one.
I married Joe 33 years ago.
We became best friends 40 years
ago in Parlin, New Jersey.
You are in a photo on my
nephew's my best friend's
son's Facebook.
They ran into you guys
recycling in Nutley one day.
Michael and Nicholaus Licamelli.
He's a physical therapist and a carpenter.
You remember that?
- We were flipping, it was
when I was doing Trash Talk.
I do remember that.
- We're very dear friends.
Leslie and I, their mother
are friends since the 3rd
grade and the father's
friends with my husband
since the 6th grade.
Just a little background on who we are.
- I love the community.
- And why I connect with you.
My work then led me to the fitness world,
where I was what they
call a lifestyle director.
I personal trained.
I ran spas and fitness
centers in luxury condos
and hotels in Miami, New York
and I live in Palm Beach now.
When we left New York
and New Jersey were like
the escaping the 36 first cousins.
It was a big deal.
My in-laws cried like
they were at our funeral
and we built a house near St. Augustine
and I started a little
dance studio in my house.
And eventually I had a brick and mortar
at a Publix plaza and I
had over 250 students.
Joe and I have relocated almost 19 times.
Because he's in the auto
industry and he became
a fixer, like I'll fix the dealership
or you'll sell it or whatever.
- I got it.
- He's still in that work 33 years later,
32 years later.
We've got two amazing kids
Alyssa in the City on Instagram,
310K followers.
She's a fashion stylist
editor curator, amazing 26.
Joseph 31, pop culture music journalist
for the New York Times, Diary of a Song
he made up for them.
Facetiming with pop
artists and their producers
on a quick FaceTime that
he runs as a video for them
and a Simon and Schuster
book deal for him.
I feel in love with Tom Levine yesterday
and I emailed him and said,
I will be your confidence
coach no charge and he
said, "I'll book a call."
So we're in touch.
- I love that, I love that.
- I saw my son in Tom
minus the love for himself.
I gave a keynote at an
event a few years ago
that changed my coaching business.
My business is MCCoaching.life.
I started it, it should be
Marissa Caskarelli Coaching,
I get that, that's coming.
People know me by name.
But when I realized your in
COVID to get my question,
how am I building this business.
I invested when I had nothing, on plastic.
I invested in one of the
best business coaches
and mindset coaches Fabienne Fredrickson
of Boldheart who is speaking
all honor to you lately.
I was on a live with her
Q&A and she was saying,
jab, jab, jab, right
hook, like pick it up now.
Gary's got me doing a lot more repurposing
and she has a multi-million
dollar business
Fabienne with Boldheart.
So I invested what I didn't
have with that business
coach, 'cause I was spinning
wheels alone thinking
I'm supposed to be self
sufficient, the immigrant
mindset and the artist mindset.
But that's been life-changing.
But I know I'm still not generous enough,
still not doing all the things.
The question I had texted
in was if you could
tell me one thing around content,
around my differentiator,
around how to put myself out ina big way.
You know when you say your big dream,
I have expanded myself enough to say I am,
I don't even like The Tony Robbins,
'cause I just want to say
the Marissa Caskerelli
of women, middle-aged
and a few amazing men,
to fall in love with
themselves, to get clear
on their messaging and to persevere
to the dream that they want
because I've lived several dreams.
I don't have money to show for it,
but I gotta lot of heart.
And I'm gonna get the
money because I'm gonna
help so many people.
- Let me promise you this,
if you had enough money to pay the bills
enough to have a lot of
heart, you fuckin' won.
Marissa, I'm being very serious with you.
Like A, just even thinking about business
coaches and how entrepreneurial you are
and just listening.
Before I go into the
answer and I have very good
insight, I think it's gonna help you.
I really really want to make sure,
like I promise you, you are just so happy
and charismatic right now,
like I can't wait to look at the Twitter
screen in between your
call and the next one.
Because you just made
half the audience fall
in love with you.
I just want to say this very slowly,
it's very important to me.
Much like Joe like fixes,
like when you and you operate,
you look at where they're wasting money,
who the bad employees are.
It's like Bar Rescue right?
You come in you audit and you fix it
and they either flip.
I think of it that practical.
When I hear your story, please do not put,
putting money in the bank
or buying some bigger
on a pedestal.
You've got way too much
happiness pouring out of you,
so I'm a little bit less worried about,
and actually I'm really excited right now
because it's gonna lead to my answer.
Your, the biggest issue a
coach has with the world
I live in is subconsciously
even when they're
sweet as fucking pie like you are,
subconsciously 99% of their content
that that they put out on the internet
is in the intent of a lead
gen to get them to sign up.
You've been in subscription
business your whole life right.
You have the studio 250 people,
they were paying a
monthly fee to go there.
You're in a coaching framework now,
which I'm sure sits in
probably a monthly fee
or a one-time fee.
And what people struggle
with is when they're
putting out an Instagram, a YouTube,
starting a podcast, doing
Zooms and Hangouts like this.
Practically you understand
that it is putting
yourself out there and
putting out good information.
The big reason I've been
able to ascend to a different
level than the far majority
of people that look like me.
Is because I have zero intent
to get one dollar from you.
And that's the end.
Right, you have two
children, I do as well.
That's called unconditional love.
As much as love our friends,
as much as we love our best friends
that we've known since 3rd grade.
We could cut those
people for our children.
It's just the way it is.
In that because you do love that friend
that you had since 3rd grade,
you do love that first cousin,
you do love other people.
In that little delta of your
children versus everybody
else is the magic and
that is the small variance
that I need.
I need you to understand the following.
That you need to produce unlimited content
and unlimited access.
Let people go on Zoom with
you, it holds 100 people.
You just talk, you just shoot the shit.
If you get to a place
mentally where you can do
a one or two hour Facebook
Live or Zoom or hangout
and have zero mentions
of your coaching, zero.
You will be stunned at how
that leads to actual coaching.
- I love that, I can commit to that.
I have no, I don't feel any
resistance or reservations
to that.
I do click to something
that leads to one more quick
thing that will allow the
shift to really happen.
- Please.
- Which is immediately
from this high I got this,
like the deflation of
a balloon when it goes.
I got that around.
Okay so I come out there
and I got two or three
people here and there and
I have a lot of people
that I've met networking live that are now
networking with me on Zoom.
I was on a BNI at 7:00 this morning.
Like the work ethic is there.
And those people were sending
me text during the BNI.
Like we love you so much, we're so happy
you're part of our club.
Thank you for what you do for us, right?
But I, the attraction, like I study,
I'm a yogi of 20 years and meditator.
I study law of attraction and
all of that, I get that work
and I'm wondering what is
the missing link right now,
what is the shift that I
have to make to attract.
- The intent.
- And probably getting
out in a bigger way.
Oh, I'm listening.
- I think it's the intent.
Right now you're so, and
I love where you're at,
I think it's not a bad thing.
But I do think it's a thing.
I think the intent is I'm gonna build,
I'm gonna do this thing
and then four people
are gonna sign up for coaching.
- You're not wrong.
- I know Marissa.
I know I'm right.
- It's what I say
to my husband I know you're right.
- I know I'm right on this one.
- And I'm not that person.
- No, you'll appreciate this.
I actually know that,
which is why I'm giving you
this advice.
I said, I don't blame you
for that, you're trying
to build a business.
It's just that I need you to
separate church and state.
When you make content you
are Marissa full heart.
And then you come out
of it when you're done
and maybe they'll be somethings
there to do business.
Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Give, give, give and then you can ask
and something will happen.
What I'm very good at,
I'll give you an example.
I put out everything for free.
Have no coaching, have no mastermind.
Have no island, it's all fuckin' free.
Then occasionally I put out things like,
hey would you sign up for
Wine Text and buy wine
from my dad's business.
- I did it, I did it yesterday!
- Thank you.
And then people that have gone and taken
all the content for free and
have changed their financial
and happiness life will so go to Publix
and Ralph's and BevMo and
Total Wine and buy Wine
and not buy from Wine Text.
And the fact that I am
not disappointed in that
is why I win.
There are hundreds of thousands of people,
there are thousands of
people watching right now
who've gotten extraordinary
levels of value
from me, who buy wine at the supermarket,
on Wine.com and have not
signed up for Wine Text.
It's for my dad, not even me.
And I'm okay with that.
That, that is the punchline.
You want to talk about a fuckin' secret.
Not being disappointed
when you've given so much
and somebody hasn't had
the ability to connect
the dots to give a little bit back.
To put a little karma back into you
and you're still not disappointed in them,
and you're still not sad for yourself.
Do you know how many
people who sell courses
and all this thing, like the lowest common
denominator guy and gal
out there making millions
selling bullshit make
fun of me behind my back
in those inner circles because they think
they make so much more money than me.
They're fucking confused,
they're fucking confused.
A, I'm gonna make way more money than them
because I'm more talented.
B, I'm gonna be around
forever, they're not.
C, I'm a better human being
and putting more kindness
into the world, they're not.
- You know when I texted again yesterday
one of the things I said as a new question
was I'm open I want Gary
to call me on my bullshit.
And it's so weird when we
know things intellectually
but we're not really rolling that way.
So for the last Tea with
Gary Vee's I've been on
and at the time time, I'm like oh shit,
two hours of my day.
I'm trying to work and
listen and whatever,
but my point is this, I know for sure
because I wrote a blog
and I don't write blogs
regularly I'm gonna get on it.
But I wrote radical generosity.
I know the keys to happiness and the first
one of them is radical generosity.
And I mean radical and
again I'm not practicing it.
I say I show people how
to show up authentically.
I am authentic it's who I am right.
But I say I do it so they lead with heart.
Like my heart is frickin' open.
- I see it,
I see it.
- I'm not doing it enough
and I'm not saying come
let me support and guide you.
- Also, also.
It's about expectations.
I don't have the expectation
for anybody to do anything
in return for something.
I don't give, giving is giving.
And right now in coaching
land I see a lot of sweet
people manipulating.
They're half their best selves
because if they leave a little back,
they hope the person comes
in and pays them $200
a month.
- Can I just say one little
thing Gary about my story
that just dropped in, so
it feels like I'm compelled
to share it?
So I had suicidal ideation a lot of times.
When Joe and I first got
married there was a major
betrayal, he had a
serious addictive problem
and hid it from me for
all the years we dated
and it hit us.
And he left me a Dear John note.
First year of marriage, lease is up.
I call the building management and I said,
listen I have a personal
problem, crying right.
And how do I renew my lease.
They said, honey your
lease was up yesterday,
you gotta be out in two days.
Picked up the phone can
called the Licamelli's
best friends, called my parents.
Packed the boxes, he said
I can't tell you where
I am because I'm in deep
shit and I don't want
you to be in trouble.
Like these things, these
kind of things happen
in '08, bought the big
McMansion dream home.
He worked for General Motors,
I tried a mortgage adjustment on my own.
I nearly took my own life,
thinking that a frickin'
thing was worth it.
But it was really about
what will I tell the family?
What will I tell my kids?
- Other people's opinions.
I used to think that I
didn't survive anything
'cause I didn't have
breast cancer or something.
I survived all that and
I learned to thrive.
I wake up ready to go and
I know that that's a value
to people.
It isn't about me.
It's about we've all got resilience
and brilliance.
- So Marissa.
- Inside us.
- So put that out for free
and then if they happen
to want to have one-on-one
access to you then mazel tof.
But if you don't put out for free,
if you don't put that out for free.
You'll never attract because the intent
is to funnel them, not to save them.
- I got it, I got the takeaway
and I got what I wanted.
- Church and state.
Give, give, give, give,
give and then something's
gonna happen, that's it.
- That's a total shift
right now is happening
and I am gonna act on it today.
- I love you good luck.
I love you too Gary, thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
That was a good one, I
think that's gonna help
a lot of people who are trying to sell,
who are also nice people.
Ah man this is great, Christie
Richards thanks for watching.
Thank you so so much.
Oh Andy Freed with the, I love this,
this right here is my favorite screen,
the Wine Text confirmation.
Dustin it's more fun for
me to get people to sign
up for Wine Text for my dad
'cause he gets so excited
at night when I see him here
'cause I'm hanging with
him during this thing.
Like 84, it's really more fun.
Like literally we close
like a $4 million piece
of business the other day
and like three people singing up right now
and sharing on Twitter,
the confirmation screen
to Wine Text is more
exciting than that deal.
That's when you know what you're about.
- [Dustin] Yeah, I kinda get it.
- All right, let's keep it going.
- Hello.
- Hello Lana how are you?
- I'm good, it's La-na like Lana Bananas.
- Lana it's such a pleasure.
Lana I love your background I want to sell
all of it on eBay.
- Well good, look I'm making masks.
- You're so amazing
thank you for doing that.
- It's like more time
consuming than I thought
but obviously I got plenty
of fabric so I'm home.
I'm home from work.
I'm fortunate, I'm nervous,
I'm fortunate that I have
a job that I actually
not laid off.
I was sent home and I'm still being paid.
So I'm grateful, I'm
very grateful for that.
So--
- What can I help you with?
- My question, my
original question actually
has been answered pretty much
because I've been watching.
I have a great job but has
for a long time career.
And but my whole life I
have stuff spins in my head,
all of these ideas and I
harass and torture my family
with oh, I should do this.
Oh, I could do this.
Or like my kids, oh you
guys should do this.
And I finally a lot of
personal things happened
and then I'm in a place in my life where
I realized that all of my
decisions (muffled speaking)
in my in teens
have been based on
fear. (muffled speaking)
- It makes sense, it makes sense.
People that love the word
should are always scared.
- Yeah, isn't that funny.
And I never realized, I
mean all of these choices
and bad decisions I can go back to where
I've always been like,
oh it's Tim, my husband
or it's my job and my boss is an asshole
or whatever, but I finally
realized that all of those
things, I chose to be
in for whatever reason
and that I was always afraid to change it.
And once I figured that out
that I don't have to stay
in this job, I don't have
to stay in this marriage
or whatever it was.
It was profound.
I had this major breakdown, hysterical,
let it all out.
And I know that I can do
better that I am better
and all of that.
So it's been very exciting actually for me
because now I kind of
started something small.
Like losing weight, mid
life women can't lose weight
(muffled speaking) and everything
and I was actually able to do that.
And I thought, well if I
can do that then what else
can I do that I thought was impossible.
- I love that.
- Like running a marathon.
I frickin' hate running.
I hate more than running
more than anything
I was an athlete and hated running.
- Lana have you thought about sharing this
and putting out content
and inspiring others,
because what you're doing take an enormous
amount of courage and I'm getting inspired
in the last 45 seconds.
- (laughs) I have, I shared
a lot with close people--
- Because I'll tell you, I'll tell you.
You're inherently private.
I can even tell in this thing.
So putting that out more,
I actually think is gonna
more light, to more happiness.
- Sure, sure and I'm totally open to that.
And so each kind of thing, I set this goal
and I go I know that I can set a goal
and it's a matter of figuring it out
what I have to do to get there.
Instead of thinking oh, saying
I'll never be able to do it.
Because even in my 30s I have five kids,
I have two now.
I've already made my bed,
this is gonna be my life
I can't do all of these things
I thought I was gonna go.
- You got time.
- Yeah, the realization was
I and my kids are adults
now, I have my whole life I
can choose what I wanna do.
- Lana, how did you first find my content?
- By accident, like a video, I
was probably watching a video
and you know how it'll
start rolling on Facebook
and then there you were.
And the first one was when
you were talking about college
and kids.
Because I have five kids
that I'm constantly trying
to encourage and when
you were talking about
college not being worthwhile.
It really hit me because
I've been pushing them,
you know a couple of them.
You need to go to school
and that was very--
- It hit you.
You realized that college
is not for everyone.
- Yeah, and it's totally
true and I did that.
So that was probably a relief for them,
because now I'm like
what do you want to do?
I'm willing to support
whatever it is you want to do.
But it started with that
and (muffled speaking).
We have a struggle with our
kids and why aren't they
getting better grades and
they gotta go to this school
all the crap.
And it's so stressful
for us that we carry.
And--
- And there's no correlation
between good grades
and happiness and that
is something that parents
have to learn, the end.
- Right, I agree and I've
figured that out looking
back because my kids are adults.
That out of everything that
I wish I would have done
better is their confidence.
Just their--
- That's it, self-esteem,
self-esteem, self-esteem.
- Yeah, oh my gosh and I
feel like in my attempt
to encourage and you know
with them I think that
I failed because they don't--
- Well, here's good news.
Here's the good news.
The good news, in the same
way that you kind of had
this awakening, like
Lana out of this call,
which obviously your
questioned got answered
so we're just riffing.
Listen to me, don't dwell, just do.
No dwelling, just do it.
It doesn't matter how
you did it in the past,
you have your whole life
and their whole life
to change the words that
come out of your mouth.
You can start now, it's not too late.
It's just not.
- Yeah, and well thank
you I'm trying to do that
and live on crap, because
I gotta lot of crap
in past I can live in.
- It's clear to me which
is why I'm trying to pound
into your head, listen to me,
it just doesn't matter.
There is no changing that.
There is no fucking time machines.
- Right.
- Who gives a shit?
- Right. (laughs)
- And people want to
dwell, because dwelling
is similar to should.
It's an excuse not to do.
You understand, staying
in that well, I fucked.
It's an excuse not to do and
the fact that you fucking
ran this marathon, you need to do.
You did the physical version of it,
now you need to do the
emotional version of it,
every single day.
Sure I can do that.
So, I have a lot of ideas
and I actually started
writing them down because
it makes me so crazy and I--
- Can you do me a favor?
- Yes sir.
- Can you put it on a dart
board or just close your eyes
and poke a pen to one
of them and just do it.
- I'm going to and I appreciate you when
one of the messages that multiple
people answered oh my God,
that's exactly what my question was
and then I'm just gonna pick one--
- Pick one.
Lana, just pick one and after
four months if you don't like
it, you didn't waste time.
You learned that you didn't like it
and then you go to the
next thing on the list.
- Exactly and I'm sure that
I'll learn a lot as I go.
- All right Lana thank you so much.
- Thank you for everything.
- Have a great day take care.
All right Dustin, I'm live.
Two year, that's what
I told you last night.
I know I told you, you
didn't hear me last night.
Jim.
- Hey.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- What's going on, is you
have a tremendous setup
behind you, I'm very impressed sir.
- Yeah, I have a bunch of
stuff going on. (laughs)
- I see it where you from?
- On Long Island, Smithtown.
- Nice, my pleasure.
- Yeah, yeah.
Where can I start?
- Wherever you want.
- So many amazing people
on this show yesterday,
Tom today, Marissa, so much.
- We're building a little
community here right.
We got like a little tea club.
- Yeah and I feel like
I got a lot of answers.
- Good that's okay.
- Out of all the other.
- So, why don't we do
this, which makes sense.
'Cause to your point a lot
of things have common themes.
Let's do this because I
think this is really fun.
What would you like to happen?
Like what are you doing
and what do you think
as of this second,
theoretically would make you happy whether
in your soul or professionally,
like how are you thinking about that?
That's a good starting point.
Yeah, so I do this live
interview show, Smithtown Live.
I'd like to get more involved with that,
but then that takes away
from my real estate business.
So that's my big question is--
- Let's talk about that,
that's a great question
as you're about to help
a lot of people Jim.
So, there's Smithtown Live,
which is your side hustle,
your hobby that probably
in the back of your mind,
if you can get enough
advertisers and enough viewers
you'd love to do full-time
because you fuckin' love it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then there's the
real estate business,
which pays the bills
and is a real business.
- Yeah.
- So you'd like to have
more time for Smithtown Live
because the real estate takes up time
and so obviously the
Smithtown Live is the thing
you love, makes sense right?
So the biggest question I
have and a lot of people
living this scenario is
what, give me a typical day
pre-corona, how many hours
on a Monday through Friday
or the week, however
you want to position it,
would you spend on real estate?
Tell me the truth don't bullshit me,
how many hours?
- For the--
- Real estate.
- For the week, probably 60--
- Per day, per day.
- Per day.
- Or the week however you want to do it.
A typical day.
- Typical day 8-10 hours.
- Love that.
- Between prospecting and advertising--
- Yeah, it's real work.
What takes up time besides Smithtown Live
and the work?
- Um, (laughs) my losing track
and signing up for webinars
and I get lost really quick.
I could watch two hours of GaryVee
and you know I'm like oh crap, I gotta go
and do that right there.
- Do you enjoy learning?
You enjoy that process?
- Yeah, I absorb, I go
on YouTube in the middle
of the night.
- Yeah, I get it.
So with, how is Smithtown Live doing?
Is it a podcast, is it a
YouTube show what is it?
- You know it started out
to be live local interviews.
They were prerecorded and
then I put them out as a--
- A live.
- A live, yeah.
- Smart, I like that.
How many have you done?
- Probably a little over 20-25.
So now putting them into Zoom calls.
I'm calling all the local businesses
that walked to the chamber
and saying hey let's go live,
I'm doing one tonight and
I'm gonna kind of combine
them into like a trivia show with a--
- Are you, love that, are
you doing this as a hobby
because you love your local
town or is there a part
of you that hopes that
all the local businesses
kind of find a way to give
you $500 to $1000 a month
as a sponsor and this
becomes your business?
- You know I'm really not
looking for sponsorship.
For me it was more I want
to do it for my town.
- And that bring awareness to you.
- And it amps up my exposure.
- Was that something that
you had heard from me through
the years because I'm a
big fan of this thesis.
Well listen, then I'm
thrilled because to your point
I was kind of hoping you would go there.
Brother, make 2200, I want the principal.
I want the mayor, I want
every single fucking business.
I want parents.
I want the high school coach.
Just ham.
- Yeah, so now that's been
a little bit of an obstacle
is I go to businesses and they're like,
they always think I'm
coming in with a ploy.
- Tell them you're not.
Tell them the truth.
- I go, it's no charge to you.
It's hard to--
- Good news, then go to the next one.
You haven't asked every
business, you haven't asked
every local official,
you haven't asked every,
you just haven't.
Well un or try to convince
somebody, don't convince anybody
just ask the next person.
Jim one of the biggest
reasons a lot of people
really struggle with
sales is they put so much
energy convincing someone
instead of realizing
just go to the next person.
- Okay.
- No convincing, just jumping
to the next opportunity.
Because let me promise
you when this starts
getting going, then the
ice cream shop is gonna
be saying, shit, why did the tire store
and the florist and the
therapist get this and I didn't?
I gotta call back that guy,
what's his name again, James, Johnny.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yeah, so what was the second,
so how do you parlay the real
estate and the Smithtown Live
together?
I know like you throw up
your little text for wine
yesterday, but I'm trying
to keep them separate.
- I think separate's gonna work.
I think you post them on YouTube.
You put the show everywhere,
that's gonna index on
search and inevitably,
you're gonna make one video
that people don't understand,
it's about 800 videos
that do nothing for you
and then one video with a dentist
that for some reason populates
the top of Google Search
and all of a sudden when
people are thinking about
this town to move to it,
they see this video of you.
You end it with, this is Jim
Hayden, I'm a real estate
agent in this wonderful town
and you've been listening
to Smithtown Live.
And they're like, wait a
minute, he's a real estate agent
and away you go.
That's why I like principals
and superintendents
and teachers because school
districts are a big part
of people deciding.
So if you're the one who
interviewed all the teachers
and all the coaches
and all the principals,
you got a real shot of
showing up somewhere
on their search and their homework,
which then leads to
trust, which then leads
to you being their real estate agent.
- Okay.
- Got it?
- Okay, yeah.
- That's what you gotta do.
- Can I another question?
- Real quick.
- So, this whole corona thing, everybody,
how do I motivate other agents around me--
- Action.
- And myself.
You know I just came from.
- Ah there you go.
- I just came from,
I took a couple months off,
my brother passed away.
- Sorry to hear that.
- Yeah, now I'm back and then
all of a sudden this corona
thing happens.
- Brother honestly, Jim,
you know what you and I have
the pleasure of, we've lived
life a little bit right?
We're not 20.
You've lived life you
know that this is part
of the game unfortunately.
Listen, I'm talking like a big shot.
I don't know, it might
take me years to recover
from a sibling's death.
Like I can't even project that pain.
A, don't beat yourself up
if you're not motivated,
because maybe you're not done mourning.
The corona thing is the corona thing,
guess what?
It's better than the Black Plague.
Guess what, it's better than World War II.
So like that just something that happens,
this is a time to be
grateful for your health
and the other people that you love.
Be grateful for the opportunity
and I would just go HAM
on content creation,
but not try to convince.
There's plenty of teachers right now
willing to talk about how
they're getting through corona,
how they like the town, their career.
Everybody wants a little bit
most people want a little
bit of fame and so if you
asked to have them on the show,
you'll do quite well.
Just pile into your passion.
Using Smithtown to build
up the real estate thing.
It will work, you just have
to put out the content.
Brother, I put out years of wine content.
- Yeah, I know I've been watching you.
- My brother knew you from
way way back in the day.
So I'm actually going
to send you his book,
he just finished writing a
book before he passed away.
- Please do that.
Send.
- Right here.
- An email to, I love that.
I'd like to honor him by
checking out that book.
So Gary@VaynerMedia.
Good luck Jim, put out the content,
don't convince just do.
- Okay thank you.
- Thank you brother take care.
All right Dustin let's keep it going,
a lot of emotio%ns here on
Tea with Gary Vee this day.
Okay the Wellness habit thank you,
thank you so much for singing up.
Be by the Cloud guy.
- Morning Gary.
- What's good Robert?
- Hey, how's it going, how's it going?
Sorry I'm driving to work right now,
but I've been listening
to you all morning.
- Beautiful bro, just keep
your eyes on the road,
you talk I'll listen.
- All right, all right, all right.
So I mean I guess I know
you're on the road here,
so I'm gonna try to keep it going.
I know my heart beating says
that I never done nothing like
this, but my question,
this is already killing me
'cause I don't do well with public view.
But it's kind of sort, I
guess it's making it easier
for me to keep my eyes on the
road and not make eye contact.
- Even better, even better, good.
- So I'm not stuttering
and saying anything stupid.
- There is no stupid.
Robert, Robert there is no stupid bro.
There's just the shit that's on your mind.
I really wish people realize that.
There is no stupid, there's
no smart or stupid question
on some real shit.
There's just Robert
living his fucking life
and he has a random
thought, get that stupid,
get that thought out of your,
let me cut that shit outta
your mind right now forever.
There is no fuckin'
stupid, there's just you,
there's just me, there's just Dustin.
There's just Jim.
Like fuck that shit.
Who, who gets to say
something stupid, fuck that.
- Yeah, you're right, you're right.
Absolutely right.
And I know one of the first
things you're probably
gonna tell me is I'm too
young to worry about this shit
but one of the things I struggle with most
right now man and I'm 27-years-old,
I got three beautiful
kids and a beautiful wife.
And I struggle with trying
to make life in my eyes
worthy for them and for
my children in the future.
- I love that, so first of
all, let me give you some
good news.
The fact that you even
care about that means
that you're gonna make it worthy.
I think Robert might be
going through a patch.
Driving, damn.
- [Dustin] Oh, I think he's back.
- Robert?
- Yep, I'm here.
- So Robert, the fact that
you even care about that
means that you're gonna make it worthy.
Bro, do not make this about
anything more than giving
love with the proper intent.
It's as simple as that.
Like you're gonna make it
worthy by actually caring
to make it worthy and loving the end.
It's not gonna be worthy because of stuff.
It's not gonna be worthy
because of professional
accomplishment.
It's gonna be worthy
because you fucking loved.
- Right, right, you're absolutely right.
- Like what, you're worthy
'cause you got a bigger house?
Worthy because you put an
extra zero in the bank account?
What's worthy?
Worthy's about you loving those fuckers
and putting self esteem in them.
- Yeah, I just want them
to know that there's
something more to what I can offer them
as far as what I have to offer.
I want them to know that
the world is theirs.
That they can take it back
and do whatever they want.
- Robert, just pump that
shit into their head.
Pump it, pump it.
24/7 love opportunity you can.
Bro, people don't look at
their parents based on their
professional or financial accomplishments.
They look at them based on what they put
in their fucking dome.
- You're 100%.
- I know bro, I meet people
all the time that have
gone on to have happy successful lives
that came from parents that
had crazy humble beginnings
because their parents made them believe
and kids aren't gonna
come at their parents
like well, why didn't you?
And you're gonna say, here
were my circumstances.
Heres' what happened.
You keep it real as
fuck, but you tell them,
but that was my circumstances.
Your circumstances you
got me and I'm gonna
take you to the top mentally.
- Right, right.
See and that's the kind
of person I am too.
I've always been raised that
way, for a little differently.
You know my dad wasn't
very, he wasn't a person
for words, we was very physical with me.
So for somebody like that I grew up,
it kinda forced me into this kinda show.
So another part of my question was,
I was always somewhat of a class clown.
You know what I mean I was that kid,
I was that performer.
But now as I'm older,
now we're in this world
of producing content,
excuse and putting stuff on social media.
I always find myself at that block,
where I can't do it because
I feel like that rain
of judgment just splashing down on me
like you're not funny, you're not this,
you can't do that.
You're not funny enough,
you don't look good.
Look at this guy with the
scruffy beard and the mustache.
- I like the scruff.
- Can't even grow one.
- I like it.
- Like it barely grow a beard.
- Yo bro, first of all
the scruff looks good,
I'm weirdly attracted to you.
So you're plenty beautiful
don't worry about that.
(Robert laughs)
Listen to me, your dad, your aunt,
nobody gets to decide besides the market.
You need to get on TikTok,
make some funny shit,
try your best.
The market gets to decide.
There is no human that gets to decide.
The market, aka the World.
Listen to me, get crazy about TikTok.
TikTok is the place for
funny, TikTok's a safe place
right now, it's very
nice because it's early.
Twitter was nice as first,
Instagram was nice at first.
That's how they all work.
Facebook is, it's nice right
now and it's about funny
you need to go in there and try.
Bro, you're 27 bro.
You're a fucking kid.
Bro, you're a fucking kid bro.
- I knew you were going to say that.
- You're 27, 'cause you know me then.
'Cause it's the truth bro.
- I've been watching you for a while yeah.
- It's the truth, you're a fucking kid.
Love your children, make
them feel the opposite
of what your dad made you feel.
They're learn that, that was your story
and they're gonna be grateful
for what you did for them.
And that's one chapter and
then on the other side.
Go make funny shit.
And when your friend and
your uncle or somebody says,
the fuck are you wasting your time for?
You look them dead in the
face and you tell them,
you worry about you.
You worry about, fuck
you, you worry about you.
- Right, word.
- Like every time somebody's
come at me hard growin' up
or in life of like, why are you don' this?
I got right at them
like a fuckin' gangster.
I'm like why are you
drinking at night when
nobody's paying attention?
You know like, come at them?
You know what I mean?
Fuck them.
Go into a cocoon.
You've heard me say that
if you know who I am.
Get quiet.
Love your kids, make them
feel like they can do
anything in the world,
but don't be delusional.
Don't tell them they can
dunk if they're only going
to be 5' 7", you know what I mean?
- Yeah, no, they should
be taller, I'm 6' 2"
so I'm pretty sure.
- (laughs) I'm going macro
bro, not literally through.
- (laughs) I know.
- Listen to me, listen to me.
Build self esteem in them,
which is unfortunately
not what you were fortunate in getting
and then go make funny shit on TikTok,
that is the fucking prescription
I'm giving you Robert.
- All right.
Yeah, you're right, actually
dude, I have a TikTok
account and I couple of video.
- I'm proud of you, let's go.
- And those are the most organic views.
Man I've made some weird dumb videos
and I'm like, how did I
get over 600 views on that?
But on this I didn't get anything.
- Don't think, listen to me,
don't think for six months.
No thinking, no valuing how
many views, how many followers.
No numbers, no thinking,
make, make, make, make, make.
Every little awesome creative
thing running through your
brain, make, make, make.
Got it, okay?
- Got it.
- All right Rob, take care of yourself.
- Appreciate it, thank you you man.
- Peace, I got you.
Now I'm getting into a
little bit of a role here,
now I'm feeling it.
- [Dustin] Up next we're
gonna have Celeste.
- Celeste, I love it.
All right, Shen, Shentulune, you got it.
You asked me, I'm your
16th fucking follower.
Big ups to Costa Rica.
Celeste.
- Hey what's up? (laughs)
- How are things?
- Good, I'm just, I work out of my home,
so everything's kind of the same inside,
it just feels really weird
and ominous outside. (laughs)
So I just wanted to thank
you for the opportunity
to be on here for
everything that you're doing
and how many people you help just daily.
- Thank you Celeste.
- So I own a small business,
I have for five years.
And so I know without risking,
I guess seeming
insensitive with everything
that's going on, my, I guess what I would
want to know from like your perspective
is like what is the positive,
like what is the most
positive thing that's
gonna come out of it?
'Cause like I know for me,
I definitely feel impacted.
My business feel impacted
and it's a little
bit uncertain and a little scary.
Moving forward, it's how I pay my bills
and it's been a really rough five years
with this trough of sorry of
opening your own business.
So I'm, but I'm finding
a lot of inspiration
in trying to be of service in any way,
because I don't have kids
that aren't in daycare.
I don't have kids that
I have to homeschool.
I'm not, like I'm impacted obviously,
but I'm not suffering and so
I see it as an opportunity
to like reevaluate--
- Celeste, real quick, real quick
so you don't put guilt on
you because I appreciate
the energy you're coming
with, like a shocking
amount of people aren't.
An extraordinary amount
of people are loving
this staycation, 'cause
they're getting paid.
And extraordinary amount
of people don't have
responsibilities and
an extraordinary amount
of people's businesses are
thriving because they sell
food on the internet and
people are buying more.
So A, don't worry about,
don't beat yourself
up for worrying about you and potentially
even seeing opportunity, that's okay.
You're supposed to worry about you.
And you can have compassion and sympathy
and empathy for others.
I see nothing but
opportunity for four hours
and then I go on for 15
minutes with my admin
and we send a bunch of masks to hospitals
because I can afford it.
And if you can't that's also fine.
You just saying prayers and calling people
and checking in.
You going into your phone
right now and texting
five people that used to be friends
or acquaintances of yours
that you haven't talked to
in four years and just saying, hey, taking
advantage of this time to
like see how you're doing
and just sending a little love
and showing that you care.
That's powerful.
So don't beat yourself
up, A, let's start there.
- Right.
I mean it's tough because
I do, when you do something
that is not for, like just for the benefit
of you or your business or whatever,
you do feel good.
So it's hard to, exactly
what you're saying
not feel guilt in a lot
of ways that you're not
super impacted.
- I listened to the things
I was saying and I saved
money, which allowed me to do nice things
like I'm doing right now
for hospitals and workers
and different things and employees
and all the things I'm doing.
Other people either were
silly and bought dumb shit
or just were never in a
place where they had too
much college debt or
something horrible happened.
They didn't save, but they
wanted to do something good.
They can do positive things.
I'm telling you texting old
friends and saying, hello
and thinking about you
and caring about you,
is a great deed and
putting out good karma into
the universe is a great deed.
So everybody can do stuff.
So, we put that on the side.
What can I help you with for you?
- So, thanks having said all
that and kind of realizing
that there is a lot of opportunity despite
the crisis that everyone's kind of facing.
So for me, I've noticed,
so I'm a small business
and I'm very supportive of like my friends
and just people that I
know that are customers
of mine that also have small businesses.
Like I've been encouraging like people to
go and tag their small
business or one that they love
or their friends on my page.
- You'll appreciate this.
Guilting/inspiring is not
something that's going
to do overwhelming well.
By the way, that's not to discourage you
'cause you're doing a wonderful act.
I just want to give you the
mindset of humans right now,
like I'm watching all
these people like support
your small business and then
I'm watching and reading
and paying attention and people are like,
that's cool.
But I don't wanna fucking
buy a pizza right now,
I'm fucking scared shitless about my job.
You know what I mean, so
just keep that in mind,
it's almost like, just keep that in mind.
So, and that's like the
thin line that I'm walking.
So my business is I
design and I sell women's
athletic, like leisure apparel.
So I just rebranded at
the end of last year
and I used to be just a regular ecom store
and so no I do limited edition releases
so that the concept it allows me to design
and be way more.
- Let me ask you a question.
Can you afford to do a drop
where you give the profits
to nurses and doctors?
- I don't think I can afford to do--
- Some of it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I would design something right now
that incorporates maybe
the, I guess the red cross.
Like incorporate that whole movement.
I bet you that could be
some sort of viral moment
and could really build awareness for you.
You survive your overhead
and rent and all that.
You feel amazing because
you've given a donation
to your local hospital.
Right, because even if
it's a $500, you buy $500
worth of masks and you donate.
Giving is whatever you can afford to give.
I used to give $9 and now I give more.
Like you know it changes.
And it's also a thing that can build brand
for you because people appreciate
that you're stepping up,
which then may lead to business
where we get out of here.
So that might be a model to think about,
especially if you made
the app leisure design
as a presale, limited edition
drop that incorporated
what's going on right now.
Maybe a mask in it.
You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, that's awesome.
That's such a dope idea.
And that's kind of what I was looking for.
Something to get behind
without it being insensitive.
- That's what Tea with
GaryVee is fucking all about.
- (laughs) That's fucking awesome.
- It's how I live, I live in the macro.
The clouds, the mindset
and then in the dirt,
the tactics.
I play back and forth, some of this stuff
as you've been watching
is for people here.
For you right now I'm super pumped
because that's a real tactic
that's gonna fuckin' work.
And that's gonna work and
God forbid, aka God willing
somebody in news is gonna see that.
Local news things and have you on a Zoom
and talk about why you did it.
There's something really big on this idea,
I hope you do it ASAP.
- Okay, thank you so much, that's so dope.
I appreciate it.
- Talk to you soon, bye-bye.
All right Dustin, showing
my chops here motherfucker.
- [Dustin] (laughs) We have
Christina coming up next.
- Hi Christina.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Good, there we go.
I want to make sure I have
it set up right. (laughs)
- You have it set up right.
What's good?
- So first I want to just give
big love to people out there
that are going through
a tough time right now.
I have two people, very special in my life
that are going through
some different things.
My brother is a Captain in
the Army who just retired.
His ceremony has been canceled naturally.
Also my best friend Kristin
down in South Florida,
lost her dad at the
beginning of the month,
had to cancel the
celebration of life ceremony.
I was actually supposed to
fly and I got sick myself,
couldn't go.
- Sorry.
- So my heart beats for
everybody that is dealing
with things like that.
I feel very fortunate
that we, knock on wood,
haven't had anything
tragic like that happen.
My high schooler's now a senior,
but what's kind of cool is the
things that I've been seeing
from seniors.
They're taking it well,
they're having fun with it
and just really making the best of it.
That's what you gotta do.
- 100%, 100%.
I mean listen it's
devastating to lose your prom
and your graduation, but
this is a real pandemic.
I mean we're gonna start seeing
2,000 people, 3,000 people
a day dying and we need
to have perspective.
And we need to innovate.
Like I can't wait to see
the first high school
do an entire prom on Zoom.
Like there's so much fun shit we can do.
So innovation comes from adversity
and I think we'll see a
lot of cool shit Christina.
- Couldn't agree more.
- What's cookin' what can I help you with?
- So my question to you was, how,
do you have any advice on balance?
I've heard you talk about it before.
I struggle with it personally.
I don't know if you can
see, hold on let me see.
There's my cat.
- So cute, so cute.
- You guys might know that
my cat is an internet cat
on Instagram.
- Good for you.
- I do struggle though with
keeping up with everything
that entails.
Keeping engaged with
the fans and the emails
back and forth.
- Can I give you a quick
prescription that you're
gonna love?
- Yes.
- Christina, you are keeping up with it.
You are just judging yourself.
- I am, but I feel like,
because I always feel like
I can do more.
I feel like I'm falling short.
- Because you're judging yourself.
- (laughs) But that's my
middle name, I judge myself
all the time, I'm very self conscious.
- Well, I have great news.
It's the number one fucking
thing we have to figure out.
Because it's poison.
- Yeah, and it is something
I struggle with heavily.
And I've grown over the
years, I've learned to shake
a lot off my shoulders.
- We all have.
And I can even feel it in your energy
and that makes me happy.
I just want to cut that
cancer out of your body.
I'm being dead serious with you.
Like what, it's a never ending game.
So you reply to 18 people
on average in the past
and now you got inspired
with Tea and Gary Vee
and now you're doing 33.
Well, why not 47.
You know you're posting two times a day
on TikTok, all of a sudden you to go seven
and why not eight?
Like you have to understand, judgment
is a fuckin' forever
game, it's a bad game.
- Yeah, I guess it's hard sometime to deal
with the guilt from fans
that don't understand
that what we do is just so consuming
and I mean when this all first
started when she went viral
and became famous, I was
up to three, four o'clock
in the morning.
I heard you tell that before too.
- Christina.
I have 5 to 15,000 DMs and texts a day.
- I'm sure.
- In there four people write things like
this is my last text
before I take my life.
If you do not help me
Gary, I will take my life.
Do you understand what
level of potential guilt
I have on a daily basis?
- I do, I do.
- And what you have to do
is put that into a place
of like you're just like a human being.
I'm trying to best I can.
And you're trying the best you can.
First of all, it's famous cat life.
We're so lucky.
Like let's--
- And I felt so weird that
sounds like such weird title.
- No, it doesn't sound weird.
And the same way that if
a senior went on right now
with me and was crying that
they couldn't do their prom
and that's their life.
That's their life and your life is that.
So I don't judge that, but
you have to stop judging
yourself, you're doing the best you can.
- Yeah, and I mean I have said that.
I told my husband that before,
there's on so much I can do.
- End period, period, period.
And every time you beat yourself up,
say oh my God GaryVee let six
people kill themselves today
and I mean that.
And listen my hope and dream
is that 99.9999% of them
are writing half, silly kids writing.
Yes, but do I believe
that it has happened,
yes I do believe that.
Does it break my fucking
soul, yes it does.
But what am I gonna do,
I'm not a fucking robot.
You're a fucking human being.
- I'm the same way.
- I got my own shit.
I got my own shit, I got my own shit.
- Right.
- I got my own shit.
- You're right and
that's the end of the day
when I had to tell myself.
I know that I'm trying
the best that I can.
It's not that I don't want to
because my heart is so big I want to.
I just don't have the time.
I only have--
- Christina, Christina.
And if you want to spend three hours
and watch a fucking Netflix
show and drink a bottle
of wine with your husband,
you can do that too.
- 'Cause you need to
refill your cup, yeah.
- Stop judging yourself please.
- I'm working on it, I've come a long way,
because boy it used to
eat me up a lot more.
- More, more use this serendipity.
If there wasn't corona I'm
not doing Tea with GaryVee.
There's a million people
trying to get on this show.
You got one, like more.
- I'm loving it.
- Real quick though, how
many TikToks are you making
with the cat?
- I think I have a
little over, almost 400.
- 400 posts?
Love you 400 posts right.?
- 400 TikToks yes, so we love TikTok.
- I'm super proud of
you, I'm proud of you.
- TikTok is so fun.
So we have over a million
followers now and three different
platforms, Facebook, Instagram and TikTok.
What I'm working on, I don't
know how much of my form
you saw.
So my husband's not working.
- I didn't see any of it.
- He's in a blue-collar trade okay.
Last Tuesday we got orders to
shutdown, shelter in place.
And so he's been home.
So it's like, man, he's
the majority income-earner
believe it or not.
I don't make a million
dollars a year like everyone
thinks.
And so we're having to go
back to the drawing board,
which is something I've
done a lot in my life
'cause I'm gonna circle
back to that in a second
and tell you how I
started flipping in 1997.
Oh my God, I can't wait to tell ya.
So anyway, so he is home
and he makes a considerable
amount of money, way more than I can get
with the business government
grant that just came out
or unemployment or anything like that.
Way, I'm like way more.
- I got it. (laughs)
- We have a savings account that's great.
We worked really hard to build that up.
I mean there's people
out there that can pay
their next mortgage or water bill.
So I'm not complaining at all.
- Again, it goes back to
it being your real life.
You know there's somebody
watching right now,
being like fuck, that
house looks beautiful,
look at that painting.
But the reality is you worked
your fucking faces off.
He also worked his face off for it.
- Yeah, like a lot of the
time the more you make,
the more you have, the
higher your bills are.
- Well, that's, the
bills is the key though.
That's something that I have passion for.
That's when you and him have to sit down
and really look at the bills
and really debate bills.
You have to debate bills.
Like you got a lotta.
People buy stuff.
Like by the way, you can
flip have your house.
Every human being whether
they have one little
fucking two sign, two
paintings in their house
or a lot of stuff in
their house, every human
being hates have the stuff
that's in their house
already now anyway.
- Yeah, and that's how I started flipping,
but my idea was I was gonna
tell you and I'm gonna
go back to the flipping.
Is that I'd had to think,
what can I have him do here.
I mean he's here.
We have nothing but time.
I just told you I have
over a million followers
on three different platforms for Venus.
I have grossly neglected
her YouTube channel now
for four years, it's terrible.
(laughs) It's terrible, I'm
very embarrassed about it.
- Don't be embarrassed,
don't be embarrassed!
- No time, I only have
so much, I have kids.
- You have children,
you fucking have a life,
and you built up over a million
followers on three different
platforms, every single
person that's watching right
now is like Jesus Christ
if I have 10,000 followers,
I'd rip my arm off.
You're crushing it Christine.
- Ah, I love it.
Crushing it, I have your
book you signed by the way.
Yeah, I co-run the business with him too.
So I'm wearing so many different hats,
and just stretched so thin
that I can't--
- You are, go ahead.
- You're home now.
You have nothing but time.
- Do that fucking YouTube.
- Home whatever yes,
I'm gonna assign him
to the YouTube channel,
he's game for it
and ride that channel
and hope that not only
can we supplement the income
he's not making right now
and hopefully not have
to drain our savings.
But, when everything goes back to normal,
we'll be in a better
position than we were before
because that will be permanent.
- Yes, and by the way do
you know that Facebook,
like Facebook ad revenue is
exploding, so I would also
very much focus on Facebook as well.
And there's, I'm in the
beta that there's a new
Facebook Live ad product coming.
There's just always going
to be opportunities.
- You just have to keep looking.
So it's going back to the flipping--
- How about this Christina.
What about direct messaging
every single cat brand
on Earth, cat food, cat
toys, like all of them?
- I definitely could.
That's one thing, I've been blessed again
because Venus is so unique looking,
I haven't had a lot of trouble.
Most of the sponsored post
I do, they're incoming.
I don't really look for much,
but I could.
- Stick with me.
- But here's the thing,
here's the thing though.
Again, not having, I have
to try to find balance.
I can make a whole lot
more money right now.
In fact, I probably could be a millionaire
if I wanted to cart my
cat all over the place.
If I wanted to do commercials and movies
and music videos.
- I got it.
- Turned down last year and stuff.
But I, first of all I
have my limits with her.
Then I have my limits with family
because I don't want to
take too much time away
from them.
- Good.
- That's what's most
important to me honestly
than making a million dollars with my cat.
- Good, listen to me.
Everything that I've just heard,
I'm so not fucking worried about you.
Like your mindset is so on point.
Like you'll sell this fucking
home and live in a different
home if you have to before you compromise
the things that are important to you.
Listen to me, stop beating yourself up.
You're a fucking Wonder Woman.
- I come from humble beginnings.
- Christina, Christina,
stop beating yourself up,
you're a fucking superhero.
- (laughs) Thanks.
- Period.
Please.
- I always find a way.
- Everybody can do more
and everybody can do less.
Just do you.
- This is why I wanted
to mention the flipping.
I don't know how much time I have.
- Last seconds.
- Okay, 1997, quick I
had my first son in 1997,
he got very sick with RSV.
He was in the hospital a couple of times,
I had to stop working my day job.
So I have been an avid
garage sale junkie like you
forever, right.
So I used to buy a lot of stuff for my son
when he was born from garage sales.
So I went out garage sale-ing.
Hit a garage sale, it was multi-family,
had a bunch of girl
clothes, I only had boys.
I have three boys now, never had a girl.
But something hit me that day,
that I was buying clothes off of eBay
and this like 1997, right?
Why can't I sell, so I
bought everything they had
for a dollar a piece,
Gymboree, Ralph Lauren,
Tommy Hilfiger, Gap, all
the stuff that was popular
back then, I snatched it all up.
Put it all on eBay, I got
a little system going,
and back then we're talking regular camera
developing the film.
- I remember, take out, oh
my God it was the worst,
I remember.
- Image hosting.
- Christina this is why
I want to punch all these
kids in the face.
They're like eh, it's hard.
- This is all you need now, right here.
- This is the business. (groans)
- I know it's so easy
now it makes me crazy.
Like it used to take me an hour.
- AJ used to have to
and then digital camera,
AJ had to take the disc out,
put it in a fucking computer.
It was a fucking mess.
- And even then that was before
I didn't even had a phone,
no digital camera nothing,
it was all done on film
in '97 and it was all
dial-up and you had to copy
the HTML and just change
the little description.
But you know what though,
I'm gonna tell you
I made between $1,000-$2,000
a month back in 1997.
More than replaced the job that I left
and I was home with my kid.
And so I didn't realize I was
an entrepreneur until then.
That was my a-ha moment.
- Christina, you might
be the person I'm least
worried about on earth.
I don't even want to talk to you anymore.
- It means a lot.
- I love you.
(kisses) Go.
- Thank you love you too.
- Bye-bye.
Love it, it's so good.
All right, see what
everybody's doing here.
Wine and Traveling loves
Christina as much as I did.
Here we go Scotty.
Celeste, let's follow Celeste,
who was just on right now,
boom.
- [Dustin] We have Tonya come on next.
- All right, please everybody
who's watching right now,
please take a photo of
this talk with Tonya
and share it on Twitter,
with a link to Facebook,
which is in my Twitter
profile and I will retweet
and follow a bunch of you.
Tonya, how are you?
- Hi Gary.
I'm freaking out that I'm
even talking to you right now,
I'm not even gonna lie. (laughs)
- Well, I'm glad we're here.
- So, I'm a social media
influencer/blogger,
whatever you want to call it.
I've been doing this
before it was even a thing.
And obviously this
pandemic has hit everyone
in so many different ways, which
is kind of earth-shattering
for a lot of us.
I just want to know what
do you think this pandemic
is going to do to social
media marketing for businesses
and people like me?
- Explode it.
'Cause most businesses now
realize they have to become
digital and sell through the internet.
- Right, I've seen--
- Now, now, there's also a
looming potential recession.
So brand deals may get split in half
and this is why I've been
yelling and screaming
as you know about A, save your money.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Like B, create other
opportunities besides
just brand deals.
Just being an influencer
is one dimensional.
You gotta round that out
with product services,
business, things that nature.
So in the macro Tonya, great,
because more people are
gonna look at digital
and ways to win digital.
In the micro, specifically
for influencers,
they're could be a drying
up season for brand deals,
which a lot of people rely on.
- Right, yeah I mean I think a lot of us,
I said in my form that I sent over
that I'm at the point now in my career
where brands just come to me
and it's one of those
things that you get used to
and you take it for
granted, not on purpose.
- It just becomes your life, your norm,
it's what you think.
- Exactly and then it kind
of brought out the hustle
in me again, where
creating organic content
because I have all this time now
and reaching out to
brands and pitching them.
- Where are you on TikTok?
- (laughs) I just started TikTok.
- Honey, this is a big deal,
this is why I'm so pumped.
You have to win TikTok, it's
gonna be the next platform.
You gonna lose.
You have to go hard, you
have to go back to straight
humility, nobody "knows you".
And fucking go hard, post
on TikTok, hit the share,
put it in your Instagram
story, build that back up.
So you audience knows you're there.
Make one main feed and be like,
I'm on fucking TikTok, I'm going hard.
Like you need to go.
- (laughs) I know.
I've been trying to do on TikTok,
it's definitely a different platform
and I feel like--
- But you can still do you.
You can still be you and
Instagram was a different
platform to the people that
were winning Facebook pages
and Facebook pages was
a different platform.
It's always a different
platform and the way that you
were like laughing at
everybody for not understanding
Instagram, is how they're
laughing at you for not
understanding TikTok.
You know like--
- (laughs) Oh gosh it's so true.
- You have to go and by the way it's not,
it's kids for 40 seconds,
it's already much older
than it was even six
month ago or a year ago.
I don't dance, I don't do that shit.
I put out my content.
Put out your content.
- Yeah, that's true, I just
need to hustle on there.
I just need to--
- You have to fucking work.
You've gotta get out of
that entitled mindset
because you had won in a
prior game to your point,
where shit came easy.
- Right.
- And you have to go back to early you.
- And it's a hustle.
Yeah, I mean it's brought
out so many different aspects
of that hustle mode.
- It's good.
You needed it.
- And inspired in a good way
because I feel like if don't
make something positive
outta what's going on--
- Do you understand how much
positive there's gonna be?
- Yeah.
- Stop watching the news
and reading Facebook.
Like this is unlimited
positivity for most people.
Reconnecting with old friends.
Spending more time with family,
getting back to, you know
you're gonna tighten up now.
It's kinda like working out.
You know all the brands coming to you,
let you get a little flabby.
Now you're gonna get back
in fucking get it, right.
- (laughs) That's a good
way, yeah that's true,
that's true.
- And by the way it's
unlikely that you would
have taken TikTok seriously if this,
if nothing had happened.
- Oh 100%.
- And then in three and a half years.
- I would have been like,
I would have pushed it to the side.
- And when Instagram
organic reach collapses
in three and a half years and
goes to zero like Facebook
pages, you'll stop
getting deals because you
can't reach anybody.
And then it's all happening on TikTok
and you would been like uh-oh.
- I know, no that's true.
I didn't even think about that.
All my friends are on
TikTok and killing it.
They're like, you need to get on it.
And I'm just like I'm uncomfortable.
But I feel like the best things come out
of being uncomfortable in
certain situations like this.
- Get out of high school
mindset and just make.
- Yeah.
- Uncomfortable with what,
you know what the fuck
you're doing.
Make a TikTok that looks
exactly like you would do
on Instagram but then learn TikTok,
the little sticker, the
little colors, like play!
Are you spending time consuming TikTok,
do you have the feel
of the vibe or not yet?
- Yeah, I'm consuming it.
I'm consuming it more than I am producing.
- Good that's fine.
- But I'm just trying
to get inspired and think of other ideas.
- Stop overthinking it.
It's not some new cooler
club and you were like
the cool chick at this one club
and now there's a new club.
It's not that, it's just not.
You understand?
- (laughs) That's how it
feels sometimes, I mean--
- No shit, that's why
I'm telling you it's not.
- My get into it a little
bit because I have a
seven-month-old and any baby content
just does good in general,
people love babies
and I've been trying to put him into it.
So (laughs).
- Listen to me, babies,
advice, random shit.
Get inspired and do something dorky.
Just fuckin' live, but
you got to start making
for TikTok now.
- All right, I'm gonna
fucking do it. (laughs)
- Good, bye Tonya.
- Bye Gary.
- Take care.
All right, Bobby Blackjack,
my man Bobby Blackjack.
Good news bro, I'm your 388th follower.
Also, I guarantee, we're
gonna do a guaranteed follow
on Twitter blitz right now.
If you sign up for Wine
Text, my dad's platform
WineText.com right now and post the screen
of you joining I will follow you.
Let's keep going.
Dean.
- Hey Gary how you doing?
- I'm doing super well bro, how are you?
- You know what I'm doing quite peachy.
- I love that.
(Dean laughs)
What can I help you with?
- You taking the time.
- Happy to do it.
- So I guess we'll jump into it.
So my question for you was, at what point
or maybe you never do it,
do you start divesting
or diverging from your
brand, yourself, your persona
and start focusing on
content for your businesses?
So something I've noticed
that people do better
in the social media marketing
realm, content delivery
than businesses talking.
- Uh, they do better in engagement
and building audiences, don't
forget it's social media.
It's peer-to-peer.
But they don't necessarily do
better in business results.
- Okay.
- So for example being
very effective on LinkedIn
in a B2B business right
now, you can annihilate
revenue in comparison
to an influencer who has
4 million followers.
So I would better in the
metrics that we all see.
Likes, followers, engagement.
But not better in
actually business results
if you look under the hood.
Because brands that put
out organic content, jabs,
who then come in with a
sales pitch, a right hook.
If they do it extremely well,
crush in business results.
A lot of people are really good at jabbing
and are bad at right hooks.
A lot of people are over right-hooky.
A lot of people have a lot
of followers because they're
attractive because they're funny.
But doesn't really lead to
business results, right?
So there's a little bit
of that dynamic Dean
to keep in mind.
- Yeah, because I've been, I originally,
so I have a full-time job in sales.
And then I have my own personal brand,
basically built up around high performance
and healthy living and
different just motivational
tips right?
I'm not trying to be a life
coach or anything like that.
- I got it.
You're enjoying it.
- Yeah, I just been, you know--
- And do you hope.
- Being a mentor right.
- And is there, and there's
the, and if this leads to
people being away of me of
what I do professionally,
that's a nice thing.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Do you, in your personal brand profile,
do you link to something
that shows your professional
part of your life?
- So, that's the thing,
so I have a website
that take you to my own
personal and then it shows,
like I have a podcast that I'm starting
and I have notation of that.
- What's your biggest profile?
- Huh?
- What's your biggest
profile, your personal
brand, what's that?
- So that's DeanStavrou.com
and on Facebook--
- What about on social, if
Facebook your number one place?
- Is it Facebook your number one place?
- Yeah, Facebook, Instagram, LinkedIn.
- What's your Instagram name?
- Dan Stavrou, S-T-A-V-R-O-U.
- Is it @RealDeanStavrou.
- Yeah, that's it.
- Okay, so you know, let's see.
(mumbling) Oh, that's Twitter, I'm sorry.
Excuse me I was looking at Twitter.
- Yeah, I'm on there too.
So I'm on all the platforms.
- So on Instagram it's Dean Stavrou?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Give me one second I
just want to see something.
And then it goes to your website,
the link and that goes here.
Sign up for a free newsletter.
And what do you want to have happen
with the free newsletter?
- So I was gonna do a newsletter
and I'm actually revising it right now.
I'm gonna start a podcast instead,
an interview-style podcast to talk about--
- And what's the long-term hope on that?
Do you hope to be hired
to consult businesses?
- Yeah, so my other business,
so the other business that I have.
So I work for a company
and I do sales consulting,
technical sales consulting
for large scale companies.
And then at the same
time in a previous life
and something I'm restarting
is, small business
technology consulting,
helping businesses make sense
of that.
We also me and my wife--
- Let me stop you right now there,
I apologize, finish that thought.
- We also started a fast casual brand
that we were launching here in Nashville
and not his happened so
we're kind of pivoting
into delivery.
- Of course, makes sense.
- But anyway, so we have
all this stuff going on.
And is it better for me or the business?
- Yes, you and number two is the key.
I want you to put out all your best advice
for free about what
small businesses should
be thinking about from a text standpoint.
Literally, all your
best advice, literally.
Make it feel like, hey
Rick, hey Sasha, hey Susan,
I'm gonna put out content that allows
you not to hire me and if you do that.
If you go from that lens.
I'm gonna put out such
good content, so detailed
in video form that people
are not gonna hire me,
you will be stunned by
how many people hire you.
- Yeah okay.
- Got it?
- Yeah, I appreciate it.
- You got it brother,
that is the breakthrough.
That's where nobody gets it.
That's what I do.
Watch what I do, not what I say.
I'm giving out my best
fucking advice for free.
- Yep, yes you are.
- And VaynerMedia is the
biggest, fastest growing
agency in marketing.
You know what I mean?
- That's true.
- So that, go it?
- Got it.
- All right brother talk to you soon.
Dean got it, I could tell Dean got it.
I love that.
He fucking did get it.
All right let's see who else is in here.
Signed up for Wine Text, you got it Tonya
thank you for doing that.
Boom, there's Jennifer Thompson.
Jennifer, you're gonna
be blown away today.
$46 Pinot Noir, coming
to you for under 20 bucks
a bottle, it's fucking crazy.
Dan Jordan what's good?
- Hey, good morning Gary, how are you?
- Real well, where you from bro?
- I am from Denver, Colorado.
- It's a pleasure, what
can I help you with?
- Well, first off I just want to thank you
for all you do.
I found your content a few years
ago and it's really helped.
Just set my life off and
a lot of folks I know
as well.
So thank you for that.
- Thank you brother.
- Of course.
So my goal overall is to help people
and just help people set
their businesses on fire.
That's what I want to do.
But for me to be integrity with myself,
I had to create my own business,
because I believe in doing
what I tell people to do.
- Absolutely, I'm a big fan of that.
It's very much been the foundation of why
I think I've been able to pop.
It's 'cause I actually did something.
I didn't just start off being
somebody worth listening to.
I did it and then I started talking.
Keep going.
- Appreciate that.
So I started doing
reselling of auction items.
And eBay drop shipping
and I also want to say
that I blame and thank you for the way
that I troll Facebook and Craigslist now.
- What's your best, Dan,
what's your best flip?
- Um, a clock.
I found like a not a grandma clock,
but a small clock and
I got it for like $30,
sold it for $150 so far.
- Let's fucking go.
- Ah man, it's awesome I love it.
So thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Also, I was in the process
of moving into Amazon
wholesale and FBA all of that.
But I'm also a trainer
and I developed a course
for networking to teach
people how to network
where they're serving and not asking.
I recently just moved to Colorado.
Uprooted my entire life
to do it because again,
when I tell people to go live your life.
I have to do it myself first, right.
So I've done that but
my resources are low.
My job is gone, my checks, my last couple
of checks didn't come in and I feel stuck.
I see the opportunities,
they're a ton everywhere.
But, I have a small amount
of capital that I need
the bang for the buck essentially.
So, I'm in a place where--
- Flip flopping.
- Products do I push my class,
when you feel stuck what do you do?
- You fucking attack
on all fronts. (laughs)
When you feel stuck, selling
the class, doing the flipping,
finding stuff on Facebook Marketplace,
if you're super scared of
corona, mask and gloves
go and pick it up then take it home.
Take the photo repost it,
make the arbitrage on that.
Like, what a lot of
Americans have never felt
is running out of options.
Like they've never really
had their back to the corner.
A lot of people got laid
off that never got laid off
in their lives.
A lot of people didn't save.
A lot of people just got caught.
And that's real life.
Now the good news is look,
this doesn't look like it's
gonna be the Great Depression
or 1987 or 9/11 or even
the Great Recession.
This does have light at
the end of the tunnel.
People are gonna have to
be really clamping down
for the next 3, 6, 9 months and so really
this goes down to cooking
for yourself with lower
cost ingredients.
Eating bad food
potentially, even .99 stuff.
This goes into buying
nothing, buying nothing.
This goes into look at your credit card,
oh shit, I'm signed up for Hulu, Netflix
and Amazon Prime.
This is offense on the
flipping on the course
but great defense.
This is time to be the '85 Bears.
You need to look at the,
like every-fucking-penny
that comes out of your
world, you need to tighten up
and even, are you renting right now?
- I am and I've actually
listened to a lot of what
you did and that's how I got out here.
But I used a lot of
resources to get out here.
- I respect that.
Listen, plenty people
got caught with timing.
They just bought the building.
They just bought an apartment.
They just started the business.
You know life has twists and turns, right?
The reality is like you
just gotta bunker down
for nine months mentally and I think
everybody if they just
really focus on the expenses,
I think, even if they get
kicked out of their apartment
and you live in a shitty place.
Living in a shitty place for four months.
Like, that's real talk, that's real life.
Offense and defense.
Just please make sure you
look at every single dollar
that comes out of your world
and audit the fuck outta it.
- Fair, can do.
Appreciate Gary.
- Awesome brother.
Wish you well
- Thank you.
- All right everybody thank you so much
for another episode of Tea with GaryVee.
I thought we had a ton
of good stuff today.
I hope it brought you value.
I hope you got some insights from it.
And most of all, I hope
you've passed it on
to friends and family
and then for everbody
who did sign up for Wine
Text, it's coming out
in an hour, if you love Pinot Noir.
$46 Pinot for $19 and change,
it's fucking crazy juice.
So I'm super pumped about that
and I'll see everybody tomorrow.
(kisses) Gotta go into meeting.
See ya, see ya, see ya, see ya!
Thank you Dustin on the ones and twos.
Thank you team Gary, Jake,
Sonan, everybody else
who's held up their phones to Instagram
and Twitter, hopefully you got your stands
from Amazon already, so you're good there.
Big shout out to the Reddit community,
love having you guys a
part of this, again today.
And 212-931-5731 if you
wanna get on the show.
If you wanna get on Tea with GaryVee.
212-931-5731, text in your question.
We'll see you tomorrow 9 a.m. Eastern
with Tea with GaryVee, see ya.
♪ It's tea time GaryVee ♪
♪ It's tea time GaryVee time ♪
♪ It's Tea Time GaryVee time ♪
♪ It's Tea Time GaryVee ♪